a barber shop was was a male domain
because you would also get advice on
sexual diseases because of course
everybody had like syphilis oh right so
this is a fake nose so everybody sort of
lost their noses okay this is something
you probably don't something you
probably don't know about syphilis I
don't know if we have that image of of
syphilis that I I sent
poor Jamie I told your bookie manager
Matt Staggs I said send these images to
Jamie and don't tell him any contacts if
allah some attacks sort of the soft
tissue and the image that i sent through
which he'll show in a minute on the the
guy has holes in his scalp as well oh
wow that's a photograph that is a
photograph though so you could just
cover that with a hat oh I guess but but
it was it was incredibly painful and you
al capone had syphilis and so you lost
your mind it attacked this one Gigi's
brain it was really so people today you
know I'll show these images on my
Instagram or Twitter and people be like
wow I didn't know syphilis was so bad
all the time well syphilis is also
responsible for powdered wigs you know
that story right know when it was I
forget some noble person got syphilis
and started wearing a wig yeah and when
they started wearing wigs other people
started emulating them because they were
the celebrities of the kingdom I feel
like this is a drunk history is
legitimate and the more wealthy you were
like because syphilis makes your hair
fall out as well yeah teeth fall out
yeah and so the more wealthy you were
the bigger and taller your wig would be
that is where the time big wigs comes
from oh that's interesting I mean I knew
that in the 18th century that the wigs
were getting bigger is that like the
fashions in fact my husband illustrated
book called the gin link is that and as
it's sort of like an 18th century
newspaper and as the newspaper moves on
the women would have to sit at the
bottom of the carriage because the
wigs were so high in some cases but the
women had syphilis oh my gosh yeah after
surely because it would be passed on or
so that's probably why they had wigs as
well yeah and um with syphilis you know
your nose fell off and it was so
prevalent in the 19th century that they
had no nose clubs so people would get
together yeah and they would in London
they would cheer the fact that you know
they couldn't smell anything either no I
mean it was awful
and actually one of the ways that they
treated syphilis was through mercury
which is and so when you talk about this
uh nose Club writers and yeah I
understand they were top hats and
underwear yeah pull up the thing know
about big wigs so I can see do you see
that one right up there oh yeah if you
go up wait up Jamie and go yes so that
man didn't lose his nose to syphilis but
that's an early form of rhinoplasty that
dates back to the Renaissance and you'd
have to stay in that position for weeks
while that grafted I believe this had a
cut of his for people just listening
there's a slice off of his arm that's
connected to his nose and they have
taped and strapped his arm to the top of
his head so he's to stay in this
position while his the trunk of his arm
grows into his face and then they're
gonna cut it and remove it when it
develops its own blood supply it's like
it's like the Nick if people have
watched that show Nick on they have a
scene with this so yeah it was and so
uncomfortable I'm better off with no
nose yeah you might be better off and
Mercury of course you would lose your
teeth and it just really awful kinds of
things that just didn't work
no and long did that last for the
mercury thing uh all the way into the
19th century and so there's a Fraser a
bunch of people died when they go hey no
copying you know basing this on yeah
okay syphilis hidden between powder ways
syphilis epidemic in late 1500s year of
left people with patchy hair loss go to
go to the actual the who was it was
but yeah so these noblemen they were all
gross disgusting people with STDs what
but what is the name of the guy hold on
don't scroll go back up here yeah okay
there it is louis xiv only 17 is mobster
thing worried the baldest might hurt his
reputation Louie hired 48 wig makers to
save his image
five years later King so but if you
scroll down yes both men likely had
syphilis so this is what started it all
out sir modern sensibilities like that
just looks so bizarre well not only yeah
I mean everything right no one's washing
themselves they don't know what drives
me crazy when people want to pretend
there are terrible things about life
today there absolutely are but this is
the best time to be alive ever by far
yeah people say on is this the best time
medically and it's like well hopefully
that's always true right hopefully
tomorrow is the is better than you know
hopefully we're advancing and learning
more and